it's the fighter and the kid had to run
it back cause we back at it again yeah
we gonna keep it moving like it's never
gonna end when it was brendan when it
was brian when it was just talking to
friends we got the kid calling on the
left with the fighter on the right had
to do it right
[Music]
back at it again
[Music]
this is really the fighter in the kit
we're out come on baby jeff die ladies
and gentlemen on
friday thanks for having me back boys
mlb's finest i love it here that's why
i'm holding this mr first pitch yeah i'm
excited yeah yeah you're getting you set
up how fast you pitched jeff what's here
if we were to clock your pitch i could
throw a probably uh if we're talking
fastball not a curveball not a knockout
no junk at least 55. well now daddy
threw 63 or something and that was the
fastest i could do really yeah recently
i bet i could slay if i warmed up and
stuff i i think i could hit 60s easy
yeah i'm free i think so far better than
i could well when i throw the when i
throw the first pictures i'm not trying
to throw it as fast as that no that's
where people mess up yeah and so i try
to get it in it always gets about have
you had any of them go just awful like
50 cent or conor mcgregor one time but
one time i was at a it was a minor
league game i started for the same the
salt lake city bees
that's where you want to mess up exactly
and i go out there nobody cares they go
and there's like two other people gonna
throw first pitch one's like a little
girl and so i throw it and i hold on to
it too long because i tried to really
whip it in there and it just hit off the
dirt popped over the you know thing
everyone booed me
fair
and i'm
i'm such a people pleaser i'm like what
like why'd you boom you know whatever so
the little girl throws a pitch
you know she throws it you know she
might as well spit it out of her mouth
it went like five feet and so as a goof
i go you didn't boo her i start yelling
at the crowd and then they're all
looking like this and then her dad's
looking at me like what like
the joke falls flat you just buried
yourself sorry botched the pitch and
botched a joke but i think at those
major league parks do you get a warm-up
like the day before anything some
sometimes people don't realize it's a
mound so the mounds are higher yeah
people don't realize they're bitching
down like it helps yes well i i was i
was with kevin bay he wanted me to stand
there and do some batting practice with
these like dominican starters these guys
who were just like one guy six seven
started american starters i know i know
stick seven is that guys you just say
from the dr don't say
i know i know i know
i know
you sound seventy i i know but he's six
seven he's colored
yes i was with these colored fellas and
they like baseball they even had some
asian starters make it through leave
that taking nobody
venezuelan catchers over there with the
but he routinely throws 100 miles an
hour and and i and i go um
he said i want you to see what that's
like and i go i'm not going to stand
there because i'm afraid of that i'm
afraid of getting hit and he said he'll
never hit you that's how accurate there
are and i was like until he does though
right yeah nelly does in that situation
he won't but also i'm just saying never
but but yeah sometimes i hit each other
like he gets out of control
usually yeah trying to throw john got it
so if you're throwing like a fastball on
it's almost like i know no
here's a question accurate both of you
guys that's what don't need to do it
though right how much to just get
drilled
how much
i'm not tracking the whole picture let
you let you just wait but just for my
buddies or am i on tv like if i'm going
to wgn and i'm going to we're going to
film me
you're fine dude you got all that muscle
yeah you'll be good i don't know i would
not be what you're going to suck
you're bigger than most major league
baseball players i feel like they get
hit all
the biggest baseball player besides
pitchers no but a lot of them are very
big they're they're they're 30 20 30
korean chin for the angels kurt suzuki
no
yeah but these guys baseball players
come in all shapes and sizes that's one
of my favorite things about baseball
you'll see fat guys you see little guys
tall guys almost all of them are over
200 though i mean
of an average baseball but you're above
you're like a lot stronger than these
guys yeah i'm like jeff bagwell you're
bigger than baggy not his his quads and
ass
dude juicy jeff bagwell yeah but you
bring that up gin juicy bagwell i love
that mark's built like mark mcguire jeff
bagwell uh
mark is the size of mark maguire
100. my biggest that could be
he was 270. they're a huge guy at least
that's me and mark right there those are
big boys look at that one with this
squat a fourth in the middle row that
one that is look at those things that's
jeff backwards that's it you know what i
remember you know i'm bigger than him i
remember way bigger way taller i know
stronger
but a lot of those guys are six four and
a lot of them are they're no not 40.
they're not so i stood up no they're not
i'm like so
i'm so hold on hold on hold on
size and weight of mlb player it's not 6
14 40. no it's not it's not that's not
the average but i stood in the lineup
with the yankees i could not [ __ ]
believe how big they were they were all
they were all huge and i'm talking about
a lot of them were your sides so average
players six to 207 pounds that's big
that's big
6-2 207 that's not that's average that's
average meaning
it is not uncommon to see six four 240.
i don't know why i even care so much
about this i'm so passionate about it
but like there's a ton of fat guys yeah
it's a lot of out of shape guys a lot of
facts that's what's great about base
yeah that's what's cool about it they
don't have to oh yeah pictures they just
sling it or like they're like chubby
hitters it's the only sport where you
see fat guys yeah it's great you'll see
small guys skinny guys the pitchers are
the tallest that's where that height is
coming from it comes to average
like six seven six ten yes there's a
seven foot pitcher right now correct
yeah like like the six six it's like
pretty standard for pitching because the
the angle they're coming down now
this is great is that prince fielder
this is pretty old but also it's a large
man right there this is 12 years ago but
also think about like uh was it a tuve
for the wholesale tuba yeah tiny time
you ever seen him no no he's tiny
actually i know we're making you guys
google up big bubble poppy ortiz
he's doing google jose
next to aaron judge because there's a
ton of photos of them at second base
together watch this next to erin judge
we'll just aaron judge hotel come right
up live really hit check
that picture that's that really yeah
that's real yeah so he was the mvp at
the bottom because he's the shortest guy
in the league next to the tallest guy in
the live one no
that's real that's real that's insane
he's tired because
he's like the size of like a little boy
jockey but he's one of the he's easily
the best second baseman probably one of
the best players in baseball he's tiny
that's crazy and aaron judge is a
monster you know what's weird about
baseball is i was at um
i was at javier's in newport and uh mike
trout came in there oh nice my girl like
he was just by himself not that thick no
and he came in and i was like in my head
i clocked him like that's [ __ ] mike
trout my girl's like who's that like
and at the time this is like f four
years ago yeah well he is the best
baseball player on earth yeah and she's
like that guy i know yeah yeah she's
like and nobody knows i'm like that's
baseball yeah
unless you're like
man i don't know a bunch of dudes like
we talked about before
like we know all that like nobody no no
pictures nothing this isn't an orange
county yeah like no one gave a [ __ ] dude
you know what's funny about me too is
like uh you know how people want to go
like i don't care about celebrities i
don't get star struck i
genuine i genuinely don't except when it
comes to pro athletes really oh man if
you put me in the same room with like
mike trout i would be just like asking
them all these questions
like i love the complete mike's comics
like when i saw
um oh [ __ ] what's his name great
[ __ ] comic monster uh dave attell
when i was staying at the same hotel and
he was out there and i saw him smoking a
cigarette i was like so nervous and i
was all that's what i said
you waiting for an uber too he's all
what that's all i'm i'm waiting for an
uber and he's like okay i was like have
a good day i was so nervous you just
annoyed him yeah he's like why is this
giant guy talking about this yeah i bet
it'd be cool you lived the pro athlete
thing so i've seen you around pro
athletes pretty
anything there's a mystery to if there's
a mystery like i sat next to it like i
remember this guy was like he recognized
me on the plane and he's asking me
questions right he's like um he goes uh
hey i'm sorry to bother you i'm just a
fan and i just always been fascinated
with comedy and he's asking me questions
and he goes and then he goes i'm sorry
you know how they they go i'm sorry i
asked oh they don't want to bother you
and i go dude i get it forget it if you
were a brain surgeon i'd probably be
asking you a thousand questions and he
goes i am a brain surgeon and he goes
here and he he had he was on his way to
a conference
all the things he was working on dude he
couldn't have gotten away from me faster
i was like and another question
well you know what i sat behind
christian yelich he's a really handsome
kid plays for the brewers uh bring him
up yeah he's really he's playing for the
miami marlins handsome kid you know he's
really good he looks very young but he's
a really good player play for the usa
team he's awesome i sat behind him on an
airplane
and uh so when you're directly behind
someone if they're looking at their
phone it looks like schwarzenegger's
song it's like you're looking it does
it's like you're looking at his phone
because i'm right between right now if
you're on a plane you're on your phone
i'm looking oh for sure i'm looking
forward to sure i've read some [ __ ] you
know he's going to the instagram dms and
he goes to the message request and it's
just
broad city i mean there's just so many
girls in there and he's just like man
this guy's got it well you know what i
was doing i realized somebody was doing
that to me i was looking up i i typed in
black studs or something like that
because i was sending black dudes so i
was taking pictures too
why would you do because i was i'm going
to throw it with deleon
yeah they were just talking about stuff
and i just sent them like i was like
happy monday guys and i sent them this
[ __ ] really good looking black guy
when someone saw it well i was sending i
was i googled the button brian googled
our blacks allowed in restaurants yeah
yeah yeah yeah he's like well michael
are they allowed in the front of the
plane because he's in the front
door is this legal my fiance my fiance
also like dated black dudes like
athletes in college so that turns you
off yeah i never let her know you're
using rail by rodney hey hey hold on
dude don't go there like i said
racism i would say
i'd send her pictures of a guy like that
like a really good looking dude i go i
go i'm sitting next to this guy and he
likes to swing
she's like you're such a god damn it so
she's like i got black she's cool about
her or she does she get annoyed he's the
best she's the [ __ ] best yeah but but
um i literally do that to different
people but i realized that the guy
behind me was looking i could see well
you know there's a cover you can put
over your phone where they need blurry
unless you're sure i need that i need
that because i know yeah
i am snoopy
i always think like they can look at
whatever i'm looking at and then they
might see some nudes or something that a
girl sent me but other than that what is
black [ __ ] if i'm in my case it's gonna
be
that was worth you know a lot of it's
stupid uh also like when you're on a
plane and someone's filming the takeoff
i'm gonna go
don't do that yeah oh yeah that's how i
like
if it's a young person hey don't do that
that's what do you mean
right like nobody wants to see that
no you're not gonna re-watch this
well when i was like i was on a plane it
took off but if you're at a zoo and
there's like someone just taking
pictures of them all hey same uh but
same thing i was on the safari if i can
google it don't don't post i'm on a
safari in africa and everybody's taking
pictures of the cheetah
but still even then i'm like there are
much better pictures of a cheetah lying
in the dirt right now right yeah i know
that you were there and you want to get
a cheetah but it's just a cheetah in the
dirt you're never actually going to look
at it if i'm petting a cheetah if a
cheetah is jumping on me now we got a
different story or if it's attacking
something correct like look at this
cheetah that's this gazelle dick first
then you film that first well what if
what if later in life you go i i you
know i saw a cheetah in the wild people
kids [ __ ] [ __ ] you can just go hey
oh well me my girl went to this doctor
yesterday in uh the ivf you know yeah we
want to have a girl so we're trying to
make sure it's a girl and this doctor we
sit down and it's uh and i haven't eaten
either so i'm starving and he's talking
like he's getting real detailed and i
kept trying to come up with no i
understand that so as far as the cost
just so he can jump to the next thing
and my girl hits me like this i'm like
okay
and then he's like so with the embryo
and you're gonna take a thing i know i
know that the sperm goes in so here's
the thing what are the the just give me
the percentage then the price and then
we'll get this thing rolling right and
he's like i just want a girl he keeps
powering through he's like right so the
thing and i was like oh my god halfway
through it well i'm going to leave now
my groove yeah you're so rude on it i
gotta go right because i got this and i
know how embryos and babies work and i
got this so why not let me know the
price and i'm gonna get the [ __ ] out of
her
dude she was like you're the rudest
person in the world i'm not though i'm
efficient so just tell me the price
we'll take care of it right and we'll
get out of here but also why isn't he
picking up on the fact that you don't
want to hear him because he was seven
he's rude yeah he was 70. he just wanted
and he's lonely and wants somebody to
talk yeah and he feels important when he
talks his doctor talks oh dude and he
was like you know the the chromosomes
and so there's 40 and i was like yeah
my my my ex my ex when she was pregnant
we had
our gyno was a guy who was probably like
us who was like
all right
let's just get this you know and so he
goes questions questions he's you know
these guys do this all the time yeah and
you know you're gonna have questions
from people our first time you know they
don't know and i remember my
my
ex goes i have a craving for beer i
don't know what it is i don't like beer
usually but i have a craving for beer
why and he goes
probably the carbs
more questions she goes she had a
follow-up question about the beer and he
goes yep yeah probably the quirks i
could tell he was like she's like why
like do you know is that far away's
there probably the carbs yeah get me
though
she was just like wondering why does
anyone have cravings
ob gyn or whatever i'm not lying my girl
loves this guy because he's latin and
he's i'm not even exactly he's 91. and
now he's still working at 90. he's seen
every vagina in the world any problem
that happens he's seen it so that's what
you want so she feels comfortable with
him but he can't hear well he's also not
going to perv on her too no not at all
he's just trying to stay alive yeah
exactly so i tell my girl i'm like you
really think it's the best choice like
he could die at any second you might
have to restart this process but he
can't hear very well so when we go in
there i'll just stay stuff like uh
seeing a bunch of big dicks lately and
he'll be like what'd you say i'm like
you've seen big dicks lately and he's uh
i'm sorry one more time like
uh have you been busy lately i'll just
keep throwing it fast like any very
vaginas lately and he'll be like i'm
sorry one more time i'm like hairy
vaginas like real slow my girl's like
well you're the worst person on earth
i'm like no i'm so bored i'm trying to
have something i gotta shake it up too i
gotta shake that [ __ ] don't you wish you
were autistic hey b now when you're on
the road doing all this travel man you
gotta get your greens and you need
nutrition
i need but where do i get let me ask you
a question where do i get a probiotic or
do i got a prebiotic where do i vitamin
i want 75 if i wanted 75 vitamins
minerals whole foods sourced ingredients
if i wanted if i wanted a multivitamin i
want a multi-mineral if i wanted a green
superfood blend in one serving what do i
do that's oh that's so weird because
this episode of fire kit is brought to
you by athletic greens dude they're ag
one one thing with all the best things
one little scoop all right one scoop
yeah one scoop eight ounce of water high
quality and bioavailable ingredients
dude it's the best bro and whatever diet
you're on this fills the void fills the
gaps join the movement of athletes moms
dads stepmoms step dads aunts uncles
podcasters comedies and everything in
between all right they make it easy
athletic greens is going to give you an
immune supporting free one year supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase if you visit
athleticgreens.com fighter today again
all you got to do go to
athleticgreens.com fighter to take
control of your health and give a g one
a try it's real now b you know me i
don't do anything stand up podcasting
life in general without a little kratom
well you got to you got to keep yourself
calm but focused dude it keeps right
it's dude it's my limitless yeah but
you got to be able to trust somebody
yeah i was going to say i don't trust
the wild west now where do i get i want
i want the super specios i want i want
the best like if i want the purest where
do i go when you want someone to trust
again super specious it has only one
ingredient pure kratom leaf kids is that
highest percent of kratom produced in
the world yeah dude all right and listen
100 satisfaction they guarantee it or
your money back what's up daddy trying
to try kratom now we got you super
specious gotcha
all day is it harvested exclusively in
southeast east asia and every harvest is
different huh yeah dude and once the
current supply sells out you can take a
month to restock so get on it dude take
advantage of this deal right now super
specious is giving you a massive
discount all you got to go all you got
to do is go to
getsuperleaf.com fighter use the promo
code fighter for 20 off that's get super
leaf dot com slash fighter promo code
fighter for 20 off get super leaf dot
com slash fighter promo code fighter for
20 off this delicious kratom there you
go
i'm like no i'm so bored i'm trying to
have some i gotta shake it up too i
gotta shake that [ __ ] don't you wish you
were autistic have you seen that show
love on the spectrum yeah when my face
have you watched uh the australian one
the first the first one yeah i watched
that and now i'm watching the new ones i
didn't know they made american version
dude let's make a let's make friends
with the old guy on there it is he seems
so fun i like james too like james seems
super is that the guy of medieval he's
got the blonde
he's insane though the heavy set like
indian guy this is what made me think of
it his mom is giving this beautiful
speech where she's like
he they said that he would never
graduate from school they said that he
couldn't go go to college you've done
all these things and in the middle of
her speech for his birthday he goes when
are you going to be done talking
he's the best hey so
i'm trying to i wish i could i'm not
driving he looks like type in
villain in the movie spawn and he is
he's the best spot on because it is what
it is this is my gift as a comment he is
spawn villain
played by your boy john whatever oh that
guy no there he is oh my gosh i've never
seen this yeah that's uh it's pretty
good that's amazing what's up yes what's
up dude that was in 1992
deep coffee that's him that's it
how weird is it
that weird
identical dude look at him same nose
same teeth same shape of that
same
yeah
expression
has he should consider that for
halloween oh that's sweet but him and
the girl did
what i love about each other what i love
about love on the spectrum is it goes
zero to a hundred they will go on a date
and then literally be like you want to
be my girlfriend yeah i love you yep i
love you i love you too we should get
married let's get married within 40
minutes it's no way they're very well
like the next day i've got to break up
with james and you're like what you said
i love you to him you never get another
one i'm like no no yeah you know a lot
of times high function autistics have
one part missing so there's no lead up
there's just like they look at you and
go who are you you're pretty yeah and
that's it you know but that's why the
show is so great because
you realize like the honesty like we
could all learn from like the honesty
that they have like especially if
there's not a match like the guy you
like the medieval times
he goes yeah he's great he goes with
another autistic girl and he goes
medieval times thing and he's like you
know they're doing the fake battles and
he thinks it's real he's like come on
red game
wretched no like the guy honor your
country and even she's all
she's like is this dude on the spectrum
it's like yeah [ __ ] sorry you all are
yeah so they get done and he's just you
know he's too much like yeah and she
goes
you know i think we're better as friends
and you tell he's like
but you there's no [ __ ] oh yeah
there's no like lead on like no [ __ ]
also if you win on one bad date right
like let's say you went on a date you're
not feeling the girl you would just that
would be that right they'll call each
other after like one bad day and be like
yeah i don't think that uh we're a good
match i'm i can't see you anymore
nothing i hope they're not sad and it's
like nothing open you wouldn't have to
do that after a bad day he would just
not talk to him you know he's like this
was accurate you didn't like it either i
don't watch it because it makes me sad
no no no you're wrong
you're wrong you're gonna watch it and
it's inspiring yeah they're awesome do
they find a lot of them do they find
love and then also you see them lonely
for their whole life though mostly so
hey there's this guy on there who's like
61 whatever he's never had sex never had
a girlfriend i want what if when i
reschedule my date in san francisco
sorry canceled when i reschedule
hopefully he's okay with the crime there
but when i reschedule i just want to
reach out to mike dude let's have coffee
yeah he's awesome he's so genuine and
nice he's never had a girlfriend
and my problem is they set him up on
that date that girl shows up with purple
hair i know mexican girl i'm like come
on you know here's my thing you know my
man's not interested two things oh by
the way he's like
oh you're here because again they're
very honest he goes yeah your hair is
interesting he had a picture in his mind
that he
saw and then he felt deceived he got
catfished by the hair so his dates are
fine but what i was going to say about
the yeah he's got he's good he takes
them down the fisherman's wharf they go
on boats fishing wow and he'll be like
do you like tarts she's like yeah it
takes her best tart place
and then she's like we should do this
again
she goes we should do this again he'll
go
i'll look at my schedule and i will let
you know but you know i'm very i can
tell you exactly what the problem is the
problem is that because it is such a
spectrum autism
nobody wants to be with someone farther
down the cognitive ladder does that make
sense yes well that's like homeboy so i
probably wouldn't
ideally want to date someone on the
spectrum right that sounds rude but i
probably wouldn't i want someone that's
more like at my level of understanding
or whatever it depends and then so so
they're the same
they'll be on the spectrum but they
don't want somebody who's like you know
down syndrome well it's like far so it's
like it's hard to match i dated somebody
i think who was on the spectrum and i
couldn't figure out what the oh you know
yeah like i couldn't figure out why she
was
not she was trying to she said she was
an actress
and then she she said i worked with such
and such i worked with such and such she
was so hot yeah and i couldn't figure
out what the [ __ ] was going on i
couldn't figure it out she was so hot
well you couldn't make it
why is yeah why is she not scooped up
why does she have food all over her face
right she eats like we why why is her
makeup like the joker right it's just
[ __ ] why does she have her bra on the
outside of her sweater do you know what
she said to me can't pick you know what
she said to me she said she said i knew
something was up we were on a date and
we were and we had fooled around while
we had sex she was
like you know
everything was good
i couldn't figure out and she goes with
eating dinner and she goes i said i
gotta get some plants just get planted
listen to this i said i want to get some
plants i never got this i want to get
some plants you said i you to plan for
my for my apartment i'm thinking about
getting i said something i'm i'm going
to go buy something randomly spread that
out she said you're going to buy plants
i go yeah i want a dog and you know what
she said are you on the spectrum she
said i am on the spectrum she goes i'm
dating a [ __ ] guy yeah she's like
this guy's [ __ ] i want plants in a
dog she's all yeah she's so get it man
can we finish having sex first
i'm sucking your dick what are you doing
why do you want a [ __ ] just that's
how i say that when i come all plants to
the dog
retriever imagine
even those two things shouldn't be in
the same way no she said and a dog this
is where i knew something was off i just
dawned on them i mean something's a
little i just remembered this after 27
years she said
get up she goes just get a fake one
and i said what she goes get a fake dog
and get fake plants that way you don't
have to water them you don't have to
walk it it's but it's something
dead serious that that dead serious and
that's where you were like i think she's
yeah but that that's when i went to me i
was like oh she's a genius yeah yeah
she's just like a really i thought she
was joking and then i found out she said
she worked with morgan freeman all these
people she was an extra and you saw in
one movie i'm not joking you saw just
her like her well dressed but she did
she worked definitely she did that's
hollywood but that's also generally the
same way a fake plant works yes this is
morgan yeah that's missing that's
missing something i don't know dude oh
it is i got a fake talking she's just
misleading yeah i've been saying this
i'm not more concerned that you have
your [ __ ] together and you were like i
want to
plant a dog well i was young and i was
like i wanted to make my my apartment
cool in your own story you made yourself
the autistic guy i said you're the one
on the spectrum but no you said i went
like this
yeah well i figured she was like i can't
decide should i get the scallops or
steak y'all i want
don't see that show i think a lot of
people might not watch because like oh
it's gonna make me sad no no also
kind of make sure if you're a parent and
you see the mom once the girl finds love
she's crying she's like oh my god
somebody actually loves my daughter yeah
that's a connect that's kind of a hard i
was gonna say the secret to that show is
the parents relationship yes when they
talk about their kid and like what the
journey that their their son or
daughter's been through that's when i
get teary eyed every time you don't want
to see your child alone you know but no
but no they don't mind them alone they
just are there's so much risk with a
relationship yeah oh now my son can get
his heart broken yeah now my son's gonna
have this expectation of a first date
well what's the guy that you like what's
his name uh james just from this season
i like michael from the australian
version that's dinosaurs what's up dog i
would love that i can't stand i can't
take people's
feelings being hurt but you ever see
somebody eating alone and you feel
terrible
and they think i do it every day they're
all do you have ct i'm like i do but
listen i don't have a lot of time left i
do but yeah i don't have a lot of time
jeffrey jeffrey tambor the actor said he
said there was a guy in new york city
who was sitting alone and you know as an
actor he's supposed to talk to taxi
drivers sit sit with people talk to
strangers pick up on characters and he's
tell the guy and he's like doing his
thing and he goes he starts talking to
him and he says is that good and he goes
yes i ate it every day here i said oh
good he said
they're talking and stuff and they say
i'm gonna say
i'm an actor he goes oh you're an actor
wonderful that's really amazing what are
you doing i do some theater and did a tv
show oh wow it's amazing and the guy and
he said tamper goes he goes what do you
do he goes ah nothing right now but i
plan on killing the president
oh my god he just keeps moving just kept
hitting he's like they're all what the
[ __ ] oh this guy's i'm gonna steal that
line that's hilarious
that's hilarious dude i i eat by myself
last night at this taco place by the
laugh factory it was buzzing it was it
has like like pink hot uh yeah like neon
signs you know what i'm about i was
starving i got done and i thought i was
gonna do another taco no not there it's
right by kind of the improv back there
off uh i don't know right there anyway
but i interested back like young like it
was the scene i was like i love their
top their tacos because i can eat just
the meat they'll do just the meat so i
went there i sat by myself and these
guys noticed me and they're like oh shop
what's up like what's up man and like oh
you were at the laptop yeah thanks and
they're like uh you're even by yourself
i was like yep yep
but it was packed yeah i'm just there by
myself yeah but i don't think that's
just bad i know i look like a psychopath
no you don't no people eat alone all the
time i prefer i go to a bar alone
sometimes just watching that that's a
little weird so i'll just watch the game
get some food yeah sure chat to the
bartender whoever's next to me this is
this is jeff is the last american bro
that should be your next special the
last time
we call it american
the last bro yeah last bro bender
because bro bender dude last bro there
you go yeah i got you dude
because we went to lakers game it's
driver not you know i'm driving back
it's i don't know 11 o'clock at night
and jeff goes so what now
yeah what do you mean what now he goes
you want to go to a bar or somebody in
my house absolutely not well i have kids
so i was like no you'll be up to like
five dude i'll just drop you off and he
goes oh don't drop meth at home can you
drop me off at the bar and i was like
what are you gonna do he's like i was
i'll have some something home is lonely
dude almost lonely yeah yeah you just
your house is boring drop them off at a
bar you want to get two beers
chills jeff do when you meet when you
get a girl
do you have any girlfriend friends or is
it hard to connect in that sense yeah i
mean a lot of female comics which is
shocking because they always are at war
with me but i i when when they're not on
stage i love them
no but like yeah like i have a lot of
girls that i know that are like bros
yeah yeah really yeah they got [ __ ] and
beards i don't know if they got cogs
yeah i hope not dude
how old are you jeff um 39. and uh do
you stress out about like getting a girl
like settling down
you'd be such a good dad yeah i would
love to i i'm obsessed with kids and
like also they could be fun such a good
day yeah it's just the um
i think when you stress about it is like
i don't know like i just don't i don't
think about it do you want i did for a
while yeah i did for like a year i was
like man i lost her i gotta go i'm gonna
figure this out and now you want to
figure it out with her well that's the
thing yeah i wanted to do with that
person but now that's not going to
happen i'm back to not karen anymore are
you just back not worried about it what
happened to happens yeah i don't think
you have a problem getting girls yeah
yeah but see that but that's a pitfall
because there's that you you have all
the you know options in the world and at
some point you're going to want to hang
on to one of those options have kiddos
yeah but i've only met one out of all
the girls i've ever met that i go oh
we'll do it with this one that's bad you
and i are like the kind of guys
if you put me out there again i would
date day date and then i'd i'd find one
that that would i'd be like my father oh
daddy falls in love
me too really like how many times you've
been in love
50 000.
i literally i love everybody what about
you kyle yeah same thing like i i'll
date and i raise a storm and then i'll
just find that one girl gets under my
skin
and i'll just be like [ __ ] man like like
my girl now my my fiance and i'll give
him the world like you name it like
ferrari 100 here's
i remember when it happened with joe i
got a text from him and he's doing his
thing and he just goes
like i knew something was up because
when she came to my house i had little
kids and my wife at the time said
what look at i love this girl i said why
she goes look at how she connects with
these children
and look at how classy she is watch how
she does this and she was watching you
and she she was watching her and she was
like he better lock that down because if
he doesn't then he can kiss my ass she
said something like that yeah maybe
everyone could tell you the next that
night you you you text me and you go i
like joe bro
i like joe bro i love that yeah but that
was just the first date we ever had
i was like you know you're meant to have
kids right like you're gonna be a great
mom she's like jesus christ it's
aggressive what did you say we haven't
even ordered our answers she's like what
you just asked me if i wanted a fake
plant yeah well also she shut you the
[ __ ] down the first time you tried to
make a move yeah really yeah i don't
like that she looked at him she was like
i don't know who the [ __ ] she goes i
don't know who the [ __ ] you think i am
but i'm not i don't what are you really
what is this yeah turn me off that's
terrible you turned me on more she was
wrong yes because you were the guy yeah
she's wrong yeah she [ __ ] up she's
wrong
no i've only felt that once i've only
fallen in love one time every other time
i just have fun and that's really only
once i think that's why girls fall in
love with me because like oh he just
wants to have a good time and be silly
and like have fun this is so fun it's
it's no problem the girls you're and
then the one that i did fall in love
with she goes
i'm going through a lot yeah you're like
god damn it what was her excuse
uh
i don't know yeah yeah i don't even know
from what i know of that situation like
maybe she's just not ready to jump into
something super serious yeah or maybe i
love her more that she liked me that's
heartbreaking that happened i think
that's what it was yeah
that happened oh that's that's how i've
been uh
telling myself yeah yeah yeah there was
a girl i was crazy about well that's
what he said yeah now there was a girl i
was crazy about dude and i we were like
it was all amazing i thought and we were
all set to go on a trip to europe i had
it all i bought that i bought every boy
and then we're [ __ ] we're
getting down we're getting down yeah
this is some love making dude this is
going to happen and you know what she
did in the middle of it she goes yeah
i'm not into it
in the middle of what the trip just no
it's the middle she was like we weren't
having sex we were about to she goes
yeah i'm not into it and i went because
her body like she was like you know and
i went i went well i just stopped dude i
stopped so i was like
there's is there any bigger turnip i
just stopped
and i just got up i put my clothes on i
go i i this this isn't i can see that
this isn't for you and once i know that
what's up
dude what's up and she was like no
and i go well i'm not going to talk
because the rest is denial i know what
this is i've been here i can feel it i
don't have any hard feelings i've been
here i really liked her i was like i
played the the you know but i i remember
i was like oh she's not
that was so unsexy that like kills that
you're just like
your dick is like i was so shocked i
went i i thought it was going i thought
it was just hot and i went huh
i'm pretty humbling yeah
i'm not interested
in me i left i just got in my car it was
like one in the morning i was like dude
i only know my world and you're like i'm
not individual
i felt i was like you're a day girl and
then she's like um she was like you know
i i don't want to get serious you know
i'm also seeing insert major celebrity
girl
oh my god no that happened to me uh oh
no doubt yeah no that makes sense i
would definitely go with him instead of
my dumbass yes i was uh
talking to a girl and she lives at
matthew perry's house
it's a tough game i go what she goes
yeah i'm romance with matt he doesn't
need a roommate first of all
what are you talking about 30 million
well he has like a giant guest house
there's like construction going on in
his house and i was like there's no way
you're not [ __ ] matthew 100 and she's
like she's like well no it's not like
that i was like i'm out yeah what are we
talking about yeah i had that actually
with a girl who was dating a very famous
basketball player and and she was she
was all about it and i was like this is
very strange if you did enough homework
you could figure this next one out just
the food for thoughts
i was uh i was head over heels about a
girl
like i thought she was awesome she was
probably to this day probably one of the
funnest people i've ever hung out with
she was very fun very sexy i was really
attracted to her she's very cool she
casually tells me
um oh no she didn't her friend goes oh
yeah she uh she [ __ ] deandre jordan
i don't know if you know
what deandre jordan looks like he looks
like he looks like the monster we might
be the yin and yang of uh of cock's yes
like like what is dick's the size of my
he's the biggest and i was like wait the
girl i like is also [ __ ] deon that is
that is interesting yeah that's it i was
like
maybe i'm not her type yeah this is not
gonna work yeah that's uh yeah it's a
tough gig uh so that was a pretty big
kibosh on that is a giant but it happens
with guys too like you and my girl like
my birthday party she's like jeff's
coming i'm like yeah that's my boy yeah
she's like you've known him like three
months i'm like when you know you know
she's like you're gay i've actually been
telling people that it sounds this is
going to sound real gay but let's get to
the last american yeah but uh i was like
yeah we fell into friendship and they go
what yeah i was like yeah you know you
fall in love we fell in a friendship
he's like i had the second hung out that
was like that guy [ __ ] right away
yeah but
the deleo's the one that made it happen
he's like hey do you know jeff dye i'm
like i know of him
we've never met he's like i'm telling
you guys can be best friends yeah really
he's like yeah can he come to the green
room i'm like [ __ ] yeah dude yeah i just
came okay
oh i met you the same day yeah yeah
that's awesome yeah
he invited me to the [ __ ] game but
then he was like shots back in hey what
but we that was towards the last end of
a terrible laker season we got all next
season we'll all go
you're going to love it you think you're
going to be better nick did you watch
the game last night
uh yeah i watched it was proud of steph
curry though i hate both those teams and
also had wigans not getting mvp oh you
gotta give it to stephanie they gave it
to steph cause he never got one before
but wiggins
i think so trailblazers one i'm sorry
i'm such an idiot
trailblazers
yeah i don't watch a lot of basketball
but that's this is the finals celtics
lost i was going for steph curry i like
steph curry i said my brother's like
balls deep in basketball like knows
everybody and i was like man i think
wigan should be an mvp and i think he
was the secret sauce to them winning the
series and then he goes on this whole
tangent of why it should have been this
other guy i forget what he said oh it
shouldn't have been steph uh no he got a
whole different guy yeah he had an
argument for this other guy and i was
like okay well you're too inside
baseball here yeah yeah i don't know i
don't know what i'm talking about i got
no doubt i'm glad steph won and then he
kept like giving me stats i'm like okay
dude and i go hey uh what is your
brother colleges your brothers
don't get an argument with your brother
about sports
he's lost he loves basketball let me run
this by you are you are you about joking
who plays for the yes argue how he's not
better than lebron with him and it's a
knight
joke has won two mvps back to back and
statistically it's like two different
ages two you know they're but literally
you look at the stats it's nuts
or jokes
yeah because um steph curry is probably
the bet the greatest three
yeah
already yeah you already know clay
thompson's up there too he kind of you
know he did all right well steph is like
already has all the records yeah but so
my brothers give me all those facts i'm
like yeah no doubt you know you know i'm
a dumb messiah do you think steph [ __ ]
chicks on the road and jay's like what
that's a better thing he gets chicks and
he's like no he's an of course he's
known for like bringing his wife to all
the games and i was like you're square
and then he just didn't text me back
that's how you put it into it that was a
god you asked about his sexual resume i
was like i'm gonna lose on this you know
dude a light-skinned brother mvp
superstar charming everyone knows him
he's on a subway commercial you know his
dad cheated on his mom so he's already
conditioned that yeah what are we doing
here dude let me run ice
as a lady this girl is a jelly monster
as a girl as a lakers fan i was not
rooting for the celtics i was rooting
for an earthquake just to swallow the
whole stadium and kill all those guys i
hate both those teams but here's the
i'll run this by i think i think slam
dunks should be worth three points
or why they're harder than a three-point
shot it's tougher to get there and
they're way more rare
so like now
if you got dorks just shoot because
here's the thing i know that steph's the
best three-point shooter in the world
and i just changed all the games
because of his
not fun to watch it's like you oh i
disagree it's like ufc when you guys
doing a submission thing it's it's it's
technical and it's really hard to do but
it's also not the most exciting to watch
we want ground and pound we want all
that stuff what's the same with you like
submissions i i like it but i don't know
armbar you don't dig it i think it's as
exciting to watch interesting yeah
what do you think is the most exciting
thing to watch because you know all that
stuff yeah i mean obviously a knockout
everyone knows a knockout knockout's
like a slam dunk and a three-pointer is
like a submission move
yeah i just i appreciate steph cuz he's
changed the game forever and like now
kids
are coming up like steph is the face of
like this generation so kids are gonna
be working on their like fundamentals
yeah instead like nobody can relate to
like and remember steph is only six
three at best so like a lot of kids can
relate to him nobody can relate to
lebron lebron
here's the argument for lebron when
people go uh you know michael jordan's
the best magic johnson cream abdul jabar
cool lebron is hands down this is where
the argument is lebron's the best
athlete of all time in the yeah yeah i
don't think he's the best player he's a
better athlete than jordan yeah really
physically not physically six
nine faster 260 shredded it's like magic
jordan mixed i could have played yeah
he's more like magic johnson than
michael jordan so it's like to be that
big athletic and do what he did at 40
now it's nuts but still doing it nuts on
that level
well that's what steph said recently on
a podcast he was like well any i'm like
he's about hard work so it's like you
can practice your three over and over
you can't practice getting bigger like
you can't make yourself bigger lebron
was born like steph i don't think he was
born with like crazy skills right like
yeah his dad was an mba so he grew up
shooting three pointers in the nba as a
kid which is a huge advantage but lebron
was like
nope like unless you're six nine two
sixty shredded
four four forty yeah we can't relate
somebody said when he was fourteen is
the best high school basketball player
in the country at fourteen six fourteen
thirty five yeah at fourteen yeah i mean
so he was physically they were
televising his like ninth grade
basketball game my favorite is he like
he pulls up in a hummer hd yeah
it's like
clearly someone's giving this kid's
money and bought his mom a house yeah
they figured out the serious question no
one cared like that's the future yeah
but i asked my buddy jimmy burke the
serious question i said
when did lebron james surpass me as an
athlete when was he a better athlete you
want me the real the real question age
10.
he said he's not when he came here out
of the place
he's a better athlete i say [ __ ] out of
his mom scientific that his mom's woo
there you go better athlete no but i
mean when he could beat me you line up
ten sports he beats me in in all of them
when he was six uh be realistic
12 12 you have 55 years old you have 50
like now uh at my yeah i was by 30.
let's say now yeah i would say when he
was 14 yeah definitely 14 because he was
six four two thirty five
maybe when he was 12 he'd run circles
right that's what it was like 12 years
old he said jimmy said seriously he goes
at 12 years old he was probably at that
point as big
maybe maybe maybe 13 when he was already
bigger stronger even that's puberty
isn't that crazy
of all time i've got this show that i'm
i'm trying to uh pitch to get picked up
but one of the things is we wanted to
figure out what's the youngest that can
beat me
uh in like ufc like who can beat me up
there
so we'll start with like a little kid
you know with like a like a oh like a
girl like a five-year-old i'm just gonna
pin him no i know a nine-year-old who
would roll you that's what i'm saying
like nine years old that nine's a little
small no no no but we're just gonna keep
getting bigger until we go and then
we'll go up nine's the age that could
beat me
nine is so small it's not it's not
though there's some nine-year-olds in
eddie bravo's system that would get a
hold of his ankles and tears [ __ ]
like
not
yeah there's nine year olds girls that
would rip your [ __ ] ankles off
freaks yeah and that's all they do they
die certainly certainly 12 year olds
that'll that'll because you there's a
certain strength factor like my son's 10
he's he's you're still
growing you're still a very small child
you got dad power on him yes but oh
myself
there are guys there are there are kids
that
kids are striking and wrestling
at
definitely 12 and 13. no i'm telling you
it'll be fun to watch no there's some
nights
bravo system or john downham system that
will rip your [ __ ] just no ankle
locks crazy like that's all they know
it's all they've come up with would they
be able to do it without permanently
injuring me probably not because they
have no control that would be fantastic
it's like a baby rattlesnake yeah just
phantom phantom yeah there's some freaks
out there dude well my son i don't know
why he's watching this youtube video
this soccer player this kid he was like
eight and i was like
holy yeah these kids were specialized
we're gonna have to they don't have to
make a caveat that they have to like pin
me wait no that's not there's no pin
anymore no they should submit you submit
but i don't get your back or get your
ankles like there's 10 year olds out
there i promise you that we'll do it i
think 10 pretty stretched but i don't
think so and i'm like balls deep in it
i'm telling you there's a 10 year old
what do i get to do back though i get to
fight right like i can i got to
i got to keep them away you got to start
and guard like they're not going to take
you down because you're
40. right so that's what i'm saying
though
there's like some 10 year old dagger
audience who would i say 13 year old
like ufc you know like i got to come in
the same way the ufc guy does they can't
i'm not going to let them start but
they're not going to jump to your ankles
yeah that's literally all they do
they're all there are 13 14 year olds
that'll that'll cause you give you fits
oh it's going to be awesome i'm saying
there's 10 year olds out there they're
going to [ __ ] you i love it yeah
everybody in here by the way yeah yeah
56 pounds is so small bubba 70 pounds
well what's the youngest kid that could
beat you up tiger's [ __ ] sick you
know what you're doing nobody this is
for a [ __ ] there's no child that can
beat them up there's no child is there
like what age right now right now right
there 15 year old that could be no
there's i don't believe that anybody in
the ufc i don't believe anybody in the
ufc under
under 155 could beat him up right now
i don't think that i don't think they'd
last what's that one guy with the crazy
haircut from uh ireland scotland or
whatever honor oh batty patty patty no
no no no no no no no no no no no no play
pinball no too small well he weighs 220
too small he's 220. he got a 220. yeah
but but but it's they're much they're
much smaller guys you would give me some
problems not a friend i got a hold of
you brandon got a hold up like so that
guy he's i mean he wants he's a big boy
he's training every day yeah training
every day he's a savage yeah
but as far as like basketball like how
would you do against the wnba players
crush them dude you think no i think
they'd do fine but i do think i'd put up
a very embarrassing fight that they
wouldn't want on camera yeah i agree
yeah and that brittany grinder might do
some or like yeah she's big and tall but
i'm saying they don't got the i mean
they don't have the aggression like
that's what braun should do he should
transition into a female and win seven
straight wwe championships
yeah i'd be sick and be like i'm a girl
well in college i mean like all division
1 football players played against the cu
women's basketball team and they
destroyed like don't even straight i
mean when we were guarding them they
couldn't touch the ball oh yeah but dude
just the fundamentals in passing and if
they had even an open you're [ __ ]
banking it i'm not sure if you could
even find on the internet because the
internet tried to scrub and bury this
story but there was some tennis guy who
was like ranked like
you know not even the top
500 or whatever
serena williams and gina said i could
beat him and they go all right let's do
it they thought there's gonna be some
great pr for women's sports he beat them
back to back of course and then and then
doubled down on his thing saying i said
that they wouldn't even be the top you
know a thousand men
get well you know what happened with the
women's olympic team they were doing
this it was even like a charity thing
they were just looking for competition
soccer they played against uh high
school awesome team like in houston and
those 15 and under high school boys beat
the [ __ ] up yeah they beat
and i've said this a million times it
might be controversial but like it's all
we have on these chicks is sports and
they still want to act like there's good
it's like that's that's our thing we got
you you're never going to be tennis is a
good example like the the top 500 guy
yeah i mean big really good d1 players
they hit the ball too hard if you ever
watch those guys like pepperdine i love
tennis i was watching these dudes at
pepperdine hit the they
first of all they're 6'4 second of all
they hit the ball so hard six four with
brad they're all both of them they're
all six four they hit the ball so
[ __ ] hard that's why he likes me i'm
sick and they never miss they don't miss
anything you just can't it's just
different yeah serena said after the
thing she goes well you know he's
putting spin on the ball that we've
never seen before he's also like uh i'm
trying to know what she said spin on the
ball and then like the velocity or
whatever like the way it was coming in
matters yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah dude he was
like a grown man oh yeah grown man and
the internet was like
he beat him back to back yes he's ranked
203rd in the world he beat serena 6-1 in
venus 62. it was like game
first of all 203rd in the world is so
unbelievably good it's stupid good so
this is what it isn't right right right
right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right right right right is a man that's
not a top five no but if you saw him
playing if you were a federer but bubba
you but if you saw if i'm telling you if
you saw him play
and then you saw the top 10 guy play in
your eyes you actually wouldn't see the
difference
no no it's games
those are the hit the greatest female
tennis players that have ever existed
once and i've never heard of kirsten
bratch or whatever i would have to look
at okay he looks like an open mind i
couldn't i could have told you that was
the
but nobody is nobody in the tennis world
would be surprised by that 203 in the
world is really [ __ ] i can't believe
they agreed to it i know look at him
they actually look happy that he's here
to be that good is a big deal she's too
excited on the right oh yeah they they
didn't know what they were signed up she
doesn't even know this is before he beat
the show look how thin she looks
smart those are young that's a young
yeah that's serena and venus
i love that movie king richard
yeah this was they were like yeah it's
taking nothing away from those gals but
you know it's just different
that's nick kyrie goes though dude i
think we want chain on that's a
different guy
with a chain i think one woman graduated
from the top gun program right i think
it's just i think actually it's not
sports though yeah but it is oh no no no
no but it is it's not that funny what
are you talking about i think it is no
no let me tell you why
fighting g-force and stuff like that and
and reaction time yeah what do you mean
well so when you hit block nine in a
plane or you're talking about a fighter
pilot yeah that's what i meant oh i
think they're just shooting no no top
gun well no that's not a flight event
it's pretty athletic they're they have
to be in crazy shape i think it's a
little bit like race car driving because
they're people like those aren't
athletes
there aren't no no reaction time and
physically you you drive with your ass
you're feeling the whole thing you're
feeling it yeah i think it's really
physical though it's super fast those
aren't sports yeah no what are they so
fun there's a lot of things that are
difficult comedy is very difficult but
i'm not an athlete yeah no but if i read
a book in a sauna my athlete because the
beast oh it's so different
it's so different because i think with
race car driving you are
your reaction time it's reaction so are
video games it's also physical yeah but
our video game guys athletes uh this is
a little different because this is life
and death sometimes or it's like really
also if it's life and death it makes
sense well
let's watch that car's an athlete but if
you watch them drive how physical they
are and how much weight they lose in a
race
uh it's a very physical thing right i
don't know though what do you think
i think what it is
i also think it doesn't take anything
away from them by saying they aren't
like i don't think it takes anything
away from you no like are you going to
compare just talking to lebron james
physically like that makes sense well no
you wouldn't compare he runs a 40 and a
5 no
that's not a good that's not a good
comparison because you could say the
same thing about tom brady and and uh
lebron right like so there's i wonder is
there af there are athletes and there's
athleticism right
like those might be two different things
right like the ability to i don't know
like but like danny ricardo and like
lewis hamilton the f to me f1 is a
little different than nascar right yeah
that's what i mean i'm talking about i'm
talking about f1 well that's he changed
the story now why are you saying nascar
because they got to make weight yeah i
think but then also in f1 it's the car
yeah the cars are better than the other
cars it's the car i don't know i don't
know the answer is yeah it's like a
jockey right like the jockey is
important
but they named the horse they go the
horse one yeah yeah no one names the
jockey no no it's like big brown won the
step with the [ __ ] yeah
not gary and it's hard to be a jockey
you gotta be a certain size you gotta
train but i don't think they're asking
physical thing
like so when you they're stunt driving
right mm-hmm they say drive with your
ass right you you you gotta feel the car
but is that a feel and a skill then it's
more of a skill but it's physical
sure i guess there's a physical element
well dude you're using your hands you're
using your car's doing all the things
no you're using your hands and feet
right you're using your hands and feet
what's the machine you've never driven
look at them but you're actually doing
this and you're using your body
why are you doing that you look like a
pacific rim well no because you're
you're the pedals are all like bring up
a mask i mean a [ __ ] uh formula one
driver because they're so physical
formula one's a little different yeah i
don't think any of them are athletes i
think what they do is really hard i
don't think they'd be interested so then
what makes it better what makes a better
driver what is the so so you have number
number 100 number one that's feel feel
like lewis hamilton he's so good ac is
his best car b isn't isn't shooting feel
right it isn't like shooting but hey b
it's a physical act of showing that
driving yeah cause look yeah but the
basketball isn't a machine
it's it's propelled by you right the car
is propelled by gas yeah but yeah when
they don't drive the driver has to
actually
change all the engine and wheels and
[ __ ] they're not they're not giving the
driver you drive pull up video about can
we can we do that
no because when you watch how physical
it is like what they're doing get out of
their gears and they're so is a fire is
a firefighter an athlete
it's physical you rush into a house
you're on time limit it's an athletic
you have to be
athleticism would help you being strong
and in shape that's the same thing
with the racecar drivers just like help
being chat
ricardo's the best athlete but right i
don't know if they're like could you do
it and not be athletic i bet you could
well what about so so what makes so a
boxer right their ability to see
distance angles great strikers okay then
the rest is is that like be able to like
measure distance but that's also
physicality and then you're right
right no because you're not getting hit
back
you well you are kind of right and
you're not well but but the margin for
the road yeah yeah like my bombs on
athlete because she drives down the
floor no you're going to maybe we are
maybe we're all athletes you're going
250 pounds
but if you're going 220 miles an hour
and you make a mistake
that's that's getting hit back you're
going to hit something you're going to
hit somebody else the curb and you get
[ __ ] up but that's not you there's no
there's there's no
variables with that right you haven't
said anything that's not true but none
of this makes you an athlete no it's
just really hard and difficult and
skillful you're in a sport you know like
that is like you have to define these
terms first and all agree on it and then
go does this yeah because no i just i i
don't know hey b is bodybuilding an
athlete like is phil heath or uh
uh ronnie coleman athlete
takes a lot of work oh you know
competitors are in competitions
and athletes are in sports they compete
i don't know they're competitors i don't
know the answer we're in a competition i
actually don't know how to answer that
question i don't either and i but i i
here's my thing too if if f1 and nascar
wants the other athletes i don't give a
[ __ ] dude they're competitors
bodybuilders call themselves no no what
i'm trying to say is this
what makes the difference you we have to
the best way to answer it is you got
number one number 100 in
f1 racing okay what is going on what's
the whatever it is what's the variable
what do you mean why is one better
consistently
is it athleticism money is it reaction
and physical but is reaction time
athleticism
it it's part of athleticism so so people
are not about physical so
that's not physical being able to read
the backfield as people are coming at
you yeah but you're throwing the ball
physically like what you're getting it
twisted tom brady might not run a four
four forty but his hand release time
you're driving recognize it wait how
about this if i give you when you shift
how you steer no that's very everyone
can do this everyone can do that no not
the way those guys don't right everyone
can do that if i give you the reaction
time of the st the stairway yeah all
that like what makes lewis hamilton
special like when he went to um the
shooting range like we've never seen
hand eye coordination like this right
but is that that's not a physical
athletic issue he's part of what makes
you
like a better athlete so a quarterback i
would imagine like drew brees can read a
backfield faster than
some guy and somebody else yeah but
drew's breeze is also very quick very
fast explosive yeah he throws the ball
faster than anybody tom brady out of his
hand same thing if i give you the best
race car you're [ __ ] up with tom
brady tom brady's hand
release is the fastest in the business
always has been oh yeah yes
it's a physical motion of throwing a
football i don't think that's what makes
him the best quarterback if i give you
the best race car in the world yeah the
hands gave you like a a couple years to
work on it yeah do you think you could
probably compete absolutely not that's
not how formula one works now if you
started as a kid he could yeah it's a
very very can't start now because
formula one like danny ricardo and lewis
hamilton started when they're like six
yeah all those guys start in uh boxcars
there's a reason those guys get paid
that much money well there's only 20 of
them yeah it's not a plug and play and
you're talking about red bull mercedes
yeah they get paid [ __ ] look i guarantee
you i couldn't give you lebron's shoes
and put you out on the lakers court like
like you couldn't do that the car is
doing a lot hamilton is very special
he's special for a reason one is he how
he came up but also he's got some gift
like you you can't yeah those are like
senna who is dead now but schumacher
those guys had something that most
drivers don't and they distinguished
themselves in the carts here in the
go-kart series
when they were younger they were already
winning there was something about those
guys
that that that was like that was they
had this ability to do it i don't think
they're special at all i don't i don't
know i don't know enough about what
driving you do i don't know why i don't
know why you don't argue yeah
athletes you know i don't watch it
i don't watch it but i i know that they
i know that having watched some of they
stay in shape because it helps them so
if you have a formula we have to be a
certain weight right because because the
heavier you are the slower your car is
so they have to be like 146 i think
jesus small guys yeah they're like
jockeys carjacking i don't know
i don't know man i do think it's really
into like you have to define the terms
or men's move it's an age-old debate but
it's something i never get tired of
he was like uh it's not a sport unless
it's a contact sport it's like swimming
isn't a sport and it's kind of like he
goes like that
you like you go into it and like you you
can make that interesting thing i know i
don't agree with it
got a ball
and you you compete to be the best
fatigues involved but so look at john
daly's body look
no one ever goes those baseball players
aren't athletes but there's a ton that
are out of shape yeah i just think that
like here's the thing it's just words
and labels so who really cares but for
me a sport
has athletes and a competition has
competitors so they're competing to win
a race cheerleaders compete with each
other in these matches
weight lifters compete
those are all competitions and those are
competitors and i think a sport has
athletes but cheerleading i mean
cheerleading is very physical doing
flips and jumps and all that yeah but
they're not they're not explosive
they're athletic yeah athletic
competitors oh that's athletic dude when
you can do like back hand springs and
two double flips that's not that's i'm
just looking at their boobs and butts
anyway hey dude i don't know hold on
there's a lot of guys out there you're
missing the [ __ ] point bro yeah i
don't know i mean i think f1 athletes
yeah i don't know if nascar yeah i don't
either i don't know enough about it i
don't follow it i just
anyway yeah because then our
construction guys athlete you know what
i'm saying yeah policeman
well no no i mean guitar player guitar
oh it's it's to be a
opera singer sometimes they call opera
singers athletes they'll be like he's
got a great lineup nobody around me
nobody around me right your friends say
that but nobody like who knows [ __ ]
you kidding me
that opportunity is one hell of an
athlete yeah that's not real right i bet
that's not even on the internet you
didn't say that nobody's ever said that
ever in the history of the world
brian just thought of it yeah that never
happened no one's ever looked at an
opportunity though that's an athlete
that's never happened they call him
musical athletes
there you go
you guys don't agree on what is a sport
you'd have to lay out that definition
we're not singing it's not this is going
down a stupid road and brian started
because i guarantee you no friend of his
said that opportunity he's an athlete
because i don't want him to get away
from that i would say get away from me
right
now i do think there's right some people
are athletic who play the drums like
travis barker is pretty athletic
but compared to what lebron serena
williams now of course yeah yeah who's
better magic johnson or dave grohl
all right i got out of those athletes
he's good with the guitar all right what
do you got jim all right since when did
google have this new what is that they
do it all the time that's their new logo
who is that
that's what so you got to click on it
that's the vice president of the united
states of america callan a british opera
singer
ha another
another [ __ ] athlete dude from 1866.
she wearing a wig british opera singer
teacher composer love songs yeah that's
google's trending
check this out we're not racist
yeah google's really trying to hedge
their beds here that wig is lit though
yeah it is what's her deal
we're celebrating her music
she has a football helmet on the top
right oh yeah she's looking good there i
give some current events jane give me a
silly hat isn't it
now brendan you know that most of your
most of your back problems your knee
problems your hip problems originate in
the feet i don't know do they really i
fell in love with this guy i need some
nice sandals dude dude i fell in love
with this company
because they make the best highest
quality [ __ ] vegetable tanned leather
uh herman oak flip-flops if you want
saltwater crocodile they got that if you
want stingray they got that mako shark
they got that you everything they they
have exotic letters all the money goes
by sea world on my feet animals dude you
can have whatever you want i want
multiple
sea animals on my feet they make them by
hand they make them by hand that's your
guy i want the top to be uh stingray the
bottom to be some other fish uh we can
do that we can i can give you straps i
can give you shark straps stingrays
stand on oh yeah now a lot of people
hold out on your boy elephants that die
of natural causes elephants that are
really old your boy flies down there
cuts the skin off that's what they do
and then all the money when they sell
the skins the money goes back to the
game wardens back to the reserve yes so
you can add an elephant under your feet
and believe it or not when you're
wearing that reclaimed elephant that
goes right back to the animals yeah look
at all that no we gotta donate crypto
into the elephant that is correct the
elephant has nfts uh you will never this
is the only day you will see me in these
boots you will never see out of my
toeholds i'm obsessed i'm trying to buy
into the company i'm going to be honest
with you you want to be a partner that's
how much i believe a partner that's how
much i believe and i need some sea world
chocolatey board sandals that's all the
different sea animals put some puffer
fish on there i'm going get some
what are you doing some stingray we got
hey you'll like this put some
[ __ ] eel on there they're coming out
they're coming out with sin with with
the actual flip-flop they got the first
amendment on there you believe in free
speech they got a patriots patriot
series they got all kinds of stuff does
have a world war ii veteran's skin on it
yes no that they don't have go to shop
toehold.com
t-o-e-h-o-l-d and they got a promo code
uh t-fat k for 15 off the best
flip-flops the only flip-flops you will
ever need under your feet i live in them
and there's nothing better for your feet
cured my foot problem no compromises
made by hand in vegas get some toho.com
15 off with promo code t-fat k
shop toehold um
these current events are brought to you
mostly by brendan this week
i said i'm like dude um is lit
check this out that's horrible child
eating leopard kills three kids and
[ __ ] 48 rampage as villagers hunt
that's what i've always said guns don't
kill people cheetahs dude
dude imagine being [ __ ] mauled by
that thing there's such one girl that
you know one girl he just i think she
was 10 or something just took her away
and ate her life this
was like oh cats don't kill people and
eat that mark you think no they're not
this isn't even a cat we'll get to that
we'll get to that this
and look at this it comes after two boys
were killing the suspected leopard
attacks over the weekend well dude take
care that sparked furious protest yeah
because that's not your kid you [ __ ]
i'll shoot that wait where's the uh
where was this in america or something
no no okay come on no you got to get rid
of that [ __ ] love no you're not in
greenwood village colorado you mean by a
leopard right sherman oaks yeah you're
not in tarzan wait what there's no
leopard give it that cheetah in burbank
got that guy
there that lioness pasadena's on the
loose man hey someone's got to do
something about this lion and vanilla
that's some india [ __ ] yeah that's
indian [ __ ] leopard [ __ ] here you
go mark yeah you're talking all that
[ __ ] about cats
oh yeah you love cats he's the weird cat
guy on the last episode uh brendan was
like you know they don't love you right
cause he's gonna eat you as soon as you
die and i'm like yeah you know what i'd
be proud beaten by my cats
how many cats you got uh 19 um not four
four cats yeah might as well be 19. yeah
yeah forecast after two a woman was
eaten by her 20 cats after she collapsed
at her home and was not discovered by
cops for two weeks police were horrified
when they discovered partially eaten
remains of the woman who was not to be
named after receiving a call from a
concerned co-worker uh two weeks late
[ __ ] uh the woman was a cat breeder who
kept the twenty giant main
[ __ ] yeah that's a breed they're super
big okay i don't like to change that
if we're gonna change the cleveland
indians we gotta change that one yeah
sure
uh inside her home police found her
partially eaten by surrounded by the
hungry cats yeah here's the thing they
say she collapsed and the cats ate her
how do we know those cats didn't just
murder yeah
just start like that probably only take
a few of them it says animal rescue
after where it goes the cats were left
alone on their own for two weeks there
was no food so what else is there there
we go that's my spot okay what are they
supposed to do you know don't blame
these poor cats plane crashes in the
snow you're not going to eat the other
passengers after a couple weeks it says
and some of the healthier cats have now
been rehomed to their new owners yeah
i'm gonna pass
on the hannibal
earlier it wasn't so they sold them
they had to buy those cannibal cats yeah
studies have found that cat owners who
die at home risk being eaten alive by
their hungry
monkeys here's the solution
don't die at home
scientists wait the shot can find out
after the cats broke into the research
center to feast on
decomposing corpses in colorado that
makes no sense studies show that
cataracts die at home risk being eaten
alive by their hunger
okay
but how about these zombie cats i just
made the shot and upgrade what
scientists have made the shocking
find after two cats broke into their
research center to feast on
decomposing corpses in colorado yeah so
these zombie cats are breaking into the
[ __ ] research center to eat people
gotta eat teach it see mark yeah you
still like cats never been into cats
this is the article that changed my mind
getting rid of my cats the main theory
is that cats are picky eaters uh
once they find a food they like they'll
stick with it whether it's people or not
stores that people live alone who are
devoured by the starving cats if they
have been doing the rounds for years
jordan peterson and 12 rules for life
one of the chapters is like if you see a
cat pet it right that's one of his 12
rules
but he said ascends and then he goes uh
he goes well cats technically aren't
domesticated uh aren't really
domesticated and then he goes on his
thing and i i always remember stopping
like why did he just he should explain
that what do you mean they're not fully
dead so you can't name a cat you don't
domesticate a cat yeah in other words
you can tame an elephant you'll never
domesticate it you contain you can
domesticate a dog well what are we
splitting hairs you're in the best pain
that's domesticated so there's a big
difference so you can domesticate ox
oxen you can domesticate sheep you can
domesticate cows and you use them that's
why you can milk them you can ride them
you can domesticate a horse you can ride
it you can use it to farm one of the
things about sub-saharan africa the
reason they didn't have a lot of farming
land so you had hunter-gatherer tribes
in when i say sub-saharan africa like
which was the tropical part of africa
you didn't have animals
you ever asked a question and then
regret it i i i know as soon as you get
a little inflection i'm just kidding for
10 years but what is the difference
between a message
you cannot so a zebra you could tame you
could be around a zebra if you raise it
from a baby yes that's zebra
try to [ __ ] ride it eventually he's
gonna bite you and hold on to you and
then kick you to death you could say
that about any elephants no elephants
same thing you cannot say that about a
lot of like you can have an ox you can
have a faithful dog you can have a horse
and and ride it forever without the risk
of it turning and killing you sometimes
every animal has some sort of decision
sometimes but for the most part in
general you can do it there's a very big
difference it's why one of the reasons
the fertile crescent europe ended up
modernizing fast [ __ ] because you were
able to impress yeah but i know a cat
you go like yo boom and he does the
little roll and everything like a dog
yeah yeah that cat is doing that with
lions too but you can jordan and that
cat is domesticated you can tame you can
tame a lion never domestically never
trust the cat no i don't see cats i
still don't understand the difference
elephants can do tricks too the
difference is you can never ultimately
rely on them to be harmless the way a
cow is where you can milk it where you
can ride
is too small to do a dog can live in
your house you can't do that with a
jaguar the cat doesn't want to be in
your arms like it hears a loud noise
it's hurting you to get out of you like
i don't think we'll do that jaguars
they're running the differences
yeah like like you contain some animals
their instinct can never
ever be taken out of them so they're
instincts you could never like with
antelopes do you ever wonder why we
don't breed antelopes
it's because they they're not hurt they
won't hurt so if you have them in a pen
and you go to get them they will run
into a wall and kill themselves you're
basically the
fox breeding program i sure don't
know
i missed that article mark no well they
like essentially condensed the process
of domesticating foxes by only picking
the ones that were super friendly to
humans like they'd rate the response if
you open the cage and either they're
hissing and yeah or they're friendly
they only took the friendly ones and
over the course of like 50 years yep now
you can buy a pet fox for 10 000 bucks
nice
if you guys want one my buddy sells them
he sent me a picture dude really yeah no
intro you don't want a fox not really
kind of fun
wait how much you get the [ __ ]
oh pretty expensive yeah but that's all
right
we're all me smart yeah yeah they're
smart they look cute
she's not gonna like uh miniature
[ __ ] [ __ ] on my floor for three years
like a golden doodle does because he
can't learn stuff no i don't think so oh
wow as little as [ __ ] listen i'm not
buying a fox for 500 bucks that's
somebody that caught a fox like hey i
have a fox for sale it's a wild girl at
the runyon canyon
yeah they might be a pain in the ass for
a lot of things for a good small fox
you're looking about four or five i've
got arctic fox yeah i don't know the
small ones with big ears yeah but he
probably eats two hundred dollars in
meat a week my buddy goes hey our unit
because whenever i was looking for cats
he goes hey you into foxes or sloth
foxes
i mean i'll put a sloth in the backyard
i said i'll put them in the backyard but
will you stay in the tree slots are
disgusting by the way yeah they're all
costa rica yeah exactly it's like
something
grand for a real prime fox man you're
talking five tonight will you walk on a
leash and everything oh yeah they'll
walk they'll do all the sleep in your
bedroom that's amazing that's cool i
might look into this you know how many
[ __ ] you get if you're like yeah come
to my house
yeah are you into foxes every girl's
like yeah hey i'll go you bet i got a
fox at my house like you don't got a fox
i go hey if we go to my house there's a
fox you gotta have to sleep
she goes that's fine well are you sure
it's not a dog yeah
[ __ ] it's a [ __ ] i caught a a lie i
caught a wild
my boxing coach had one when i was
coming up and uh it was so wild he put
in his uh basement yeah we had another
little cat that would put it oh hands or
paws underneath the uh jon jones has one
right now but he had a another cat that
put his paws underneath
that thing went very cool what i'm gonna
do i'm gonna rip your paws off and he
decided to rip his paws off yeah well
there's another kind what's the other
cat and they only eat live
cat it's it's it's tan look at that one
making coffee
god have you made my sprouts in the
morning
but there's another cat that's like that
called uh um what the [ __ ] is it called
it's like that it's like a lynx yeah but
it's it's
tan and even bigger than that the [ __ ]
is it i knew a girl who had one not an
oscillator maybe it's a caracal dude
yeah it's a car call dude you've got to
talk all right you got to be out of your
mind have kids and buy these oh yeah no
doubt i looked into it because they they
don't shed them yeah i know the girl has
two of those look at those i heard you
don't worry i heard you don't want a
monkey if you got kids too no the
monkeys get all jealous oh [ __ ] monkeys
you don't want monkeys
look at that [ __ ] thing dude yeah get
out
dude you have that thing at your
caribbean your dick's up
guarantee it no i mean there's a badass
look at that lady she's doing well
beautiful yeah well those are fake ears
right that's a regular tabby cat and she
put those yeah exactly that's all she
did that that's the crazy cat lady and
that's also mark and tenure look at that
[ __ ] though look at those things
they're [ __ ] gorgeous look at how big
they are though
that's cute you don't want that rome in
your house i want it to stay it's a
mountain lion with pointy ears and
they're killing everything all the birds
everything oh dude think of a house cat
how well they hunt then you can get that
[ __ ] thing from africa and then put
in [ __ ] tarzana and think it's gonna
be all good correct do you think you can
feed that thing chick-fil-a waffle fries
oh i will cool i will you look at that
[ __ ] thing yeah that's a that's a
really specific uh thing to give your
cat it's a [ __ ] mouth jeff buy one
i'm going to show you what i want to buy
i just can't find a video of that i took
a video of this look at this look at
this creep
oh dude that's a red panda yeah that
came right up to me you can't you can't
oh you're not joking yeah you gotta buy
like the red panda you gotta like it's
like
five hundred thousand dollars a year uh
from china you gotta like rent them and
the zoos only zoos can have them told
you china rents all the pandas yeah
right way to go biden yeah all right am
i right now we're gonna lose all the
pandas hey buy inflation gas get the
[ __ ] out of there let's figure out the
panda problem yeah quit renting the
pants
red panda cutest thing i ever saw so
cute now you know the the pixar movie or
the disney movie red panda is taking
some heat because all they're saying is
it's a young girl getting her period and
then she's getting shamed for it that's
what they're doing what do you mean what
are you talking about
they're saying like the the
the whole narrative of the story is it's
a teenager or like a young girl getting
her period there's like a man how people
treat her all mean because when she gets
her parents she freaks out i haven't
seen this becomes a red panda wow if you
have kids you watch it and then i do the
backstory and i'm like okay redpan's
getting some [ __ ] i didn't even know
there's a movie called red panda
the hidden meaning behind disney pixar's
turning red
you know this stuff how do you know
because i have kids and i get like
how do you know but like how would they
know what an undertone or what a meaning
of a movie is supposed to really matter
ah you get it dude
yeah you get it because remember when x
matching or x machine i remember that
movie came out all these feminists were
like it's about how
men treat women as it's a it's a thing
about how they keep women yeah and
they're right sexualized i'm stuck in uh
click on is the red panda movie about
periods click on it you see it oh this
one yep key woman's actually such a good
while parents may be caught off guard by
curious kids ask questions about puberty
or periods after seeing the film ex
experts
yeah what is excellence
the real issue is not talking about
periods at all as well as the social
stigma you know what i'm saying it's
trying to that narrative it's just how
it becomes political everybody wants to
jump on well my son wants to see that
new buzz your uh light that movie looks
terrible yeah i heard it's so bad but
you know my [ __ ] kid wants to see us
how you sit through this [ __ ] you're
gonna hate it i'll probably listen to
the [ __ ] podcast right here because
disney passed on tim allen because he's
and they're saying because he's
conservative but he also that's not true
i know that's not true
disney goes he's making a santa claus no
disney goes wrong with the character
they want those but uh tim allen is like
a comedy relief he's older this is his
origin story and he's like a hero so we
wanted to use a more younger girl i know
it's 70. also my kids don't know who the
[ __ ] tim allen right what else i know
chris evans
to his conservative beliefs because
apparently he has a deal with disney
he's making a lot of money with him
he has nothing to do with his
conservative beliefs but they wanted to
be like a hero not a comedy so they
hired chris evans here's what i don't
get about this movie
and and i watched the trailer to see if
they would address this
buzz lightyear's origin story is he was
made in a toy factory and he was he was
bought by andy's parents
so i don't understand they don't make
any attempt to explain
who's what origin story yeah it's the
original like him as a character as the
space in a movie or a comic or wait it
doesn't make any sense i don't know dude
you know what you're thinking too much i
know it's a [ __ ] but i was hoping
they'd address it at least because i was
going on all right
i'll just watch it you know i like toy
story are you going to bring your kid to
it he's got he wants to go today so i'm
thinking about going you know it's
whatever you can explain i bought him a
buzz lightyear and the woody thing
because he got into toy story for a
little bit but here's the problem when
you buy those toys on the bottom of the
foot it says andy like the movie so my
son who clearly don't pay attention he's
like why the [ __ ] is that another kid's
name did you steal this toy so i crossed
it out and got a sharpie to put tiger on
it
yes
did you write it like a little kid would
write it like yeah andy was like it's
horrible
it ruined the toys try it you don't play
with it i'm like dude your name's on it
i think i don't want it man thanks for
dude she's whack yeah but also disney
why would you put another kid's name on
the [ __ ] toy that's a little too
accurate yeah i had to cross it out it
looked ridiculous yeah he thinks it's a
used toy it doesn't want to touch it
he thinks it's used yeah do you ever get
everything about getting used toys
absolutely not no no no no absolutely
not my life's going too well right my
dad would take us to goodwill and let us
pick one thing out yeah remember my
brother got a saxophone one
but time don't happen with saxophone we
just got it
like that ain't in you yeah i bought my
son a guitar i was like wanna start
playing guitar bottom drums he's like
hey he goes
are you a musician i go no he goes
i don't have it in me i don't i'm not
interested just throw it right now
because i'm not that into music dad i'm
just going to be honest and you and
either of you
fair enough no my brother was like dad
lisa simpson plays saxophone like the
time bill clinton plays yeah he was like
he wanted
i guess i guess but hey hey dad give
some lessons dude oh yeah we don't have
a place
my daughter we buy her violin it's kind
of an expensive you know thing
she's into violin
and uh she played it three times no she
uh they're so expensive they left it on
top of the car
oh no
and that violence fell off in the road
and guess what somebody found it
and somebody returned it and it was oh
nice
and she still plays and she's an
orchestra now when i was a kid
when i was a kid they told us all we had
to pick an instrument and go home and
tell your parents to buy the instrument
and then we'll learn in music classes
yeah but my parents are so cheap and uh
rude they're like you don't want to
learn you're not going to learn how to
play trumpet i was like i don't know
they told us to pick an instrument and
so they were going we're not buying you
a trumpet so i had to go to school the
next day all the kids got their
instruments their parents you know went
over the weekend bottom the instrument i
go my parents said i can't do it and
they go what they go they said i can't
have a trumpet
and then so they go all right so when
kids would go to music class and the
teachers trying to have like an
hour-long break
i'm just sitting in the
in the classroom by myself i was just
like withdrawal like jesus christ so
embarrassing trying to get you bullied
yeah well it's also like in high school
they don't do it now because there's
ipads in every school has one but
remember when we're in heist not you so
much but remember in high school and
then make you buy a ti 83 the texas
instrument the thing was like 400 bucks
what's that the ti-83 i never made it to
that high of count but i know the
experience i remember my dad was like
what the [ __ ] i was like will you have
to buy this calculator from best buy or
whatever my dad is like it's expensive
yeah like that i literally won't
graduate unless i get a ti-83 yeah and
then you could download video games and
like write messages get your friends and
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude that's bringing back so
many memories for me watch it look into
this thing and it had a case that like
slid over the front of it oh you know
ti-83 yeah the kids had it before you
said you did no no i know i didn't i
didn't know this was called but i would
see this calculator i was like oh you
guys are in good math i was with all
like the 10th graders just trying to get
out of algebra once so i could graduate
did you even go to college no college it
wasn't in the cars my my
gpa was like had letters in it and [ __ ]
like it was i was terrible at school i
barely graduated really
it's all system though right yeah you're
a smart dude it's like school's just not
forced out what wasn't trying well it's
also like
it's not that you're learning you just
learn how to pass you need context you
give a [ __ ] when you're a kid and
they go you're gonna learn about history
kill me right now
also when are we
math is the same thing like the only
reason i kind of did well in math was
somebody
explained how your mind can work if
you're good at math you can you can
formulate a good argument and they were
like they made it relevant to me they
made it like ammo for me and then i was
like oh okay but without that [ __ ] i
think that's anything with context if
you give me a backstory i'm injured even
with me backstory like my dad was like
no you're doing this i'm like dude i
don't know what [ __ ] chapter wrong i
would love school now there's nothing
more boring there's so many characters
correct like make it more relatable dude
correct yeah school now would be great
but i just didn't give a [ __ ] back then
i just want to make everyone laugh i get
suspended all the time
like i couldn't care less like all those
field trips we went on i didn't i [ __ ]
off about all that but if you took me
now i'd be like oh well
my son now i'll be like hey dude you
wanna miss school and go to [ __ ] sea
world or something i'm like no i do i
love school i'm like yeah
and his mama did really sad his mom be
like why would you call him a dork and
like who wants to go to school yeah he
doesn't want to start your school like
god he's a nerd though you get a ditch
school and go to sea world he's like
seaworld with brendan chubb that's
another part of it you know i'm famous
right right i felt so bad the other day
i was i told my son to sweep the floor
but he didn't really like it he didn't
know how to do it yeah because nobody
really taught him how to swim and i got
oh he's a genius he's like i'll just do
this i don't know how to sweep it he's
trying to be delicate with it i could
just sweep the stuff up now i
he's like i don't know how to sweep we
know he's so bad sweet look we had this
huge fight fighting around i was like
wait hold on this kid actually just
doesn't nobody told him to hold it this
way pull it towards you there's just a
technique to it and once i told him he's
like you could have just told me i felt
[ __ ] terrible yeah you know how to
sweep though yeah i agree yeah but just
like might be a janitor one day who the
[ __ ] but also my my son will do uh like
the basics yeah he could grow he might
grow up and be yours he's got to know
the message
janitor yeah
he could take over the cleaning system
you gotta put uh sweeping tigers say
stuff like this like boston you know
used to [ __ ] his pants tiger uh he'll go
dad boss says poop get your son
who the [ __ ] are you talking that's
amazing who the [ __ ] are you yeah yeah
get your son get your son boston's poop
wow wow that's great i love that he
looks out for his little brother oh dude
yeah i told you yeah they talk the way
you talk yeah yeah yeah that's that's
where they're getting it
my son this morning's watching cartoons
with my my baby my his half brother on
his on his lap just holding onto him
they're just [ __ ] watching tv i love
that oh
yeah tiger when we you know we go to the
car show every sunday malibu but they
have a playground there with sand in it
so boss go papa take my shoes off i'm
like yeah dude let's take the shoes off
there's this little you know appearance
i don't get it man especially malibu and
there's this little girl throwing or i'm
sorry a little kid like a you know a boy
throwing sand in boston's face i always
tell tiger i'm like papa's here i'm a
grown man i can't do anything if someone
[ __ ] with your brother dude you defend
at all costs so i i'm like i'm not gonna
say anything and i see the kid throwing
sand boston's face i'm like oh in my
mind i'm blood red i'm like i'm gonna
beat this why is the cat doing it just
you know they're [ __ ] idiots yeah my
kids have never done that throwing
[ __ ] sam like i'm looking at the damn
like let's go my man does nothing i look
at tiger he's on the swings i see him
[ __ ] track it i'm like come on buddy
now's your chance jump off just take us
in
right in the kid's eyes i'm like there
we go
there we go just randy johnson's my
white arm no t don't do that let's get
out of here
bottom snacks you know
that's the way we're blinding other
children with that i mean yeah that's
just good oh man
you know what i'm saying it's a sam
right we got his hat party i don't know
tiger goes i know it's a sand party i'm
gonna come from the swings [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's like brandon brennan will like like
there are certain some actors and
they'll say i want a box and i can box
and brennan goes i'll beat you with my
i'll be like he get if you push him he
goes like this he goes
he said this one guy he goes uh i'll
i'll beat you with one hand the guy goes
what
he goes i'll beat you with one hand and
he goes but i'm gonna get real with you
i'm gonna get real with the one hand i
think i was like oh jesus all right i
guess we can play this if you want to
what is so this is like so what what you
guys are describing is like a fun like
threat but it's like also it's got some
no it's just that some guys what i'm
saying is the best one like what's like
the best one you ever heard
um well my favorite is the delta guy who
somebody said you ever kill anybody and
he goes
never stop to look brother yeah see that
kind of like movie line almost or that
or the other guy who said uh i know a
tough
guy and there was a giant man who came
at him and they were telling the story
and i looked at him i said what did you
do
because he had two black eyes his nose
was broken the guy was huge and he
looked and he just looked at me he said
i met him halfway
listen to this that's cool my one of my
best friends brant tobler very funny
comedian he's got a cousin named kato
now kato he's not as strong as you he's
not as big as us his name's kato but
cato
lives in a different world i mean cato
i've seen him get out of cars just grab
a brick and like do do business you know
like the guy he's on love on the
spectrum season three he is the best
he's the sweetest guy but also like he
he'll go there right
so we were doing the show the phoenix uh
improv and um something went down with
the bartender and there was some guy and
cato just defended the bartender's honor
that's what he claimed and we were like
nah that's probably what happened but it
turns out that is what happened it
doesn't matter this guy steps to him and
cato's not the tallest guy in the world
so we're thinking like you know what's
gonna happen here and the guy goes huh
where are you from and cato looks up and
he goes i'm from right here right now
that's great i was like that's good
my buddy did that some people
this guy football player big guy goes
what's your name and and my buddy who
loved the fight goes
[ __ ] use my name i love that henry was
on
i got a couple funny ideas one is i'm
gonna take a combat uh combat pistol
there's a guy who teaches like he's had
a lot of he's killed people he's
visiting wars and stuff and uh
he didn't say the story but the story
was
he was in detroit his he didn't know
where he was he stops to get gas and he
has this really awesome big truck
and this [ __ ] these these
gang dudes came up to him they said
gangnam yeah were they colored i don't
know what they were yeah gang started he
goes the guy goes so the guy goes this
guy's just a hard and he's a hardened
veteran like a guy they've seen some
[ __ ] yeah
and he's he's in his truck like that and
the guy goes what do you got for us man
what do you got for us and the guy pulls
up his thing is his blood pressure's not
raising he's got a gun the guy's got a
gun the gang guy's got a gun and the
[ __ ] dude the [ __ ] dude he just
goes like that and he just went like
this he goes he pulled it out of his way
he just pulled out his ways and jammed
it he grabbed me and jammed it all
knocked his teeth
like that and he pushed him against the
gas and he goes what now what now oh my
god that's what i got for you i got a
gun in your [ __ ] mouth and it's yours
you [ __ ]
now now you can die or get the [ __ ] out
of here yeah they just [ __ ] kiss like
me it's a different dude that's a badass
on saturday morning is just me mark
strolling the streets of portland like
we had food and coffee we're walking
around and it was dicey man of course i
was like that's [ __ ] weird around
here right and i know what dramatic is
you guys have homes yeah and shoes yeah
they're like
hot shots full bellies
yeah they can afford a coffee oh wow
they got beanies on but uh i'll tell
mark i'm like there's a part of me that
wants
somebody to i was like i struggle with
this there's a part of me yeah that
hopes like uh like some some gang or
something stumbles upon us
because between you and me i feel like
we could handle ourselves yeah there's
part of me that i would love to test
that theory out here let's see what
you're made of that's part of yeah
that'd be fun yeah that's on my like i
hope somebody [ __ ] with us
like these portland like this advances
would be there'd be somewhere we could
just let loose a little bit yeah but it
has to be justified because you're
honorable men yeah like no i'm not going
to believe the [ __ ] with you yeah i want
them to be like hey what the [ __ ] you
doing being wronged here what are you
doing in our coffee shop and i'd just
it'd be like uh the bronx that i'd be
like mark luck
and just squeeze him and that's that's
like is he stretching like sure
there's a comic in boston i can't
remember his name which sucks because
he'd love for me to give him some credit
here but he he got mug or not mugged but
a guy put a gun in his back and was like
basically you know help you know give me
all your money and he this is a true
story he's not not fabricated at all the
guy puts it on his back goes give me my
money he goes i got two dollars to my
name and you're gonna have to [ __ ]
kill me to get it
yeah the guy just like this is such a
waste of time yeah i'm not gonna shoot a
guy what's up rogan was talking about
this where uh there's a vet he's seen
like so many tours and he was driving in
uh when the riots were going on and he
took he was in an uber he was an uber
driver but he's a former vet and the
person asked to go someplace and he
stumbled upon where the process was
happening and the guy pulls out like an
ar-15 on him and he goes huh that's
interesting i've served seven tours in
iraq yeah so i'm pretty familiar with
the ar-15 very cool takes out his
glaciers
i'm sorry where'd you want to be dropped
off at
just shot him yeah yeah because who shot
who i'm so uber driver shot the the
random protester with the ar-15 because
he's pointed at him which is a
person that's threatening your life
that's that's that guy
with deadly force and that guy's been in
all the tourism
oh interesting when i was overseas and
someone would point a gun you're gonna
die they were trying to kill me very
cool hey bubba cool i know i drive uber
right now but i have a history
it's called rules of engagement and yeah
you pick up your right foot anywhere but
here now
i i didn't finish the rogaine episode uh
it's with that our boy
on noir noir but i'm pretty sure that
guy got charged even though the guy
pointed a
automatic rife at him he went oh cool
kiki yeah now make sure you tip me on
your way out yeah yeah that's five star
that uber driver i think you should
point a [ __ ] ak-47 to somebody or an
ar-15 that's a move of aggression well
it's rules of engagement you are you're
trying to kill me and i shot you yeah i
don't know if that guy went to prison i
i thought self-defense
the episode and jamie found out that the
investigation is still going on so we're
not sure what's gonna happen it's also
tough to texas prove that he pointed
they are 15 you could be really just
happy that witness in the back is like
yeah no 100 percent i was scared for my
life he pulled the air 15. he's like
yeah no doubt then you're all right then
yeah maybe he'll be able what's like
that uh kyle renton house he's like a
superstar because he's making all you
know look at the evidence he's always
shooting suing biting oprah
oh money dude bubba i'll make
500 million dollars probably like think
dude just go through it lebron
billionaire oprah billionaire biden
probably a billionaire that we don't
know about right
so it's like they're just going to set
them like hey each one of you morons
because you labeled me a racist said i
shot black people which i shot mainly
white people and bad people right and
there was nothing racist behind it and i
was in the court of law found innocent
and you
put a [ __ ] label out on my head yeah
and painted the narrative this way i
want a hundred million from each you
[ __ ] otherwise we're going to court
i'm for sure going to win well because
yeah like the me we're going to settle
he'll make up no joke a minimum of 50
million the trial of media suggested
like just saying kyle reynolds's name is
like but did you see what you saw
this kid was [ __ ] now but even me i
went oh that's terrible we shot black
people and then you're looking like oh
my god that guy pointed a gun at him he
defended himself he killed the guy in
the head white guys
and one white guy was a rapist like a
pedophile yeah it's insane and crazy
yeah [ __ ] those guys it's framed as
totally the opposite oh dude you watched
you're like you're i was watching the
trial closely like holy [ __ ] try to even
bring up kyle ryden has his name on
stage see how quick the audience is oh
they will i've done it you can't you
don't look at facts no no but wherever
you're happy texas is the problem
california all they know is that's that
kid that did that racist thing my friend
still did it nobody looked into it i
can't believe he's going after cnn i'm
like but they they're right he's like
they don't want to look at it i have
some uh fouchy and newsome and garcetti
jokes be care in l.a and the crowd yeah
dude they'll turn on you man yep
well which so i'm like what
like obviously they're political figures
they're up for
jokes like
no matter where you side on who gives a
[ __ ] because he's because the media
successfully connected him to
right supremacy you know whenever i made
fun of donald trump on stage nobody ever
told me to stop being political yeah
they were always so fine with it
and then i do a joe biden joke or i say
like i think i'm a guy because i have a
dick and they're like stop picking on
the trans man
you're like i'm not yeah what else you
got jen
hold up
this right here
oh so it's my boy miles teller
this is fantastic dude you know him you
know very well yeah we lived together
when i first came to l.a no [ __ ] he's
great yeah how do you how is that attack
he's really good friends with scotty
mcknight who i played football with oh
wow and i remember when i met him at
time he wasn't doing [ __ ] he was like
booking small roles
and i remember thinking god that he's
his confidence not cocky but his
confidence was crazy because he goes oh
i'm going to be the next marlon brando
and i go good luck with that you
remember that's like pretty big open mic
are going i'm going to be the next dave
italian yeah have fun with that buddy
yeah that journey is just the statement
but he but literally hell of an he's a
musician right uh drummer grew up
playing
an actor through and through yeah and he
goes oh my next marlon brando oh have
fun with that buddy anyway you know i
kept going
i mean kid's crushing it correctly but
so this story is really good oh he's
fantastic this story's hilarious so
because he you know he's in the new top
gun and he's flying the planes all the
time he he's flying the planes and he's
around the plains all the time and then
he just breaks out in hives like his
body has some crazy allergic reaction he
goes the doctor get blood work he can't
take a bath and like oat or something to
get rid of the lives and so they oat
melt and so the doctors give him his uh
toxicology report back and he has jet
fuel in his bloodstream because he's
been around planes in the jet so it's
super poisonous
this is the second method how but how
crazy this he goes up to tom cruise the
next day tom goes man you all right how
are you feeling did did you get reports
back he goes yeah man they said i have
jet fuel my system and this is the most
hollywood thing of all time tom cruise
goes i was born with it brother and
walks away
you know what
hey you know what by the way so by the
way shout out to tom cruise the greatest
guy you'd be like no no seriously i i
almost died yesterday
blood poison who is born with it he was
he passed on back goes i was born with a
brother and walked away
you'd be like
oh he and by the way i believe that tom
cruise
i mean i don't know how he was i believe
he believed he made that movie he was
60. i i don't know how old he was did i
he's unbelievable still haven't seen the
movie no i did i saw it with my son
[ __ ] unbelievable unreal i mean dude
he's still doing have you seen that i
haven't seen it i never go to movie
theater no but it's also it's all sweet
i don't like sitting by someone and not
talking i'm like oh dude dude you know
that but that one you're like my girl
it's a throwback [ __ ] like she's more
makes patriotic oh dude i was like
i was like this i don't think i needed
any more of that but
i do i can't get enough it's a reaction
to the woke thing it's a literal movie
men women
gender lines are strong america the
great it's all this [ __ ] it's like i
am this is like be proud it's honor duty
life and death [ __ ] can he be white
you think that's the biggest move in
america correct because it's because
that's oh wait but buzz lightyear is not
doing well
but explain this exactly because i
thought everyone agreed with no
it's a reaction it's a [ __ ] reaction
i don't know but why is that doing so
well it's strange yeah i know i don't
get it i feel good movie it's weird it's
not all everyone's sick of this [ __ ]
yeah and then when you celebrate america
americans go yeah that's what we're
about of all colors you got a hispanic
woman you got black dudes yeah she's the
worst pirates oh yes
i think she's so hot yeah
that movie i shot one of the wardrobe
ladies who was really cool her name's
jessica but i just said i love america
and she goes careful now and i go oh
what i just said i love america you what
you don't love america she goes that's
what she said that's how dangerous
things get started and i go saying that
i love america you kids that's how uh
that's how nazis oh
to love your country is a dangerous path
to go it's like what are you talking
about when i was uh touring overseas in
like australia i was in london dublin
and i'd go in the taxis they'd go you're
american huh and they'd like make fun of
us and i'd like
what nothing will write you're like
this is the way you view us yeah what
are you out of your [ __ ] mind dude
that's great what's wrong with country
it will fight you right what i'm not
even in the military
what the [ __ ] is happening
good news when trump was president so
like oh trump blah blah blah blah blah
that's a lot bro look at your [ __ ]
country yeah oh you're making fun of us
i can't even name your guy yeah yeah you
know our guy yeah you know our guy what
are you talking about yeah well well the
enjoying that cheeseburger dude where do
you think that came from oh so it's cool
we're like a melting pot so we have all
the cultures we can't stand with people
like that careful now and this woman
said i didn't want an american flag in
my classroom it made me feel
uncomfortable you get the [ __ ] out of
you but i would like to go [ __ ] bro i
would pull my kid from the school dude
that i draw them
all the way [ __ ] out of here then go go
somewhere else oh you do you want me to
fire you up real quick
so my my father-in-law was uh police
officer uh highway patrol for 30 years
and he retired he goes it's not safe the
new da's out of control they're letting
criminals off it's not safe for anybody
this week early in the week
two cops were ambushed and shot and
killed yeah i saw that and then the
other uh guy was shot in the face four
times he's gonna survive it but um the
two cops that were killed
because of garcon rda this guy is a gang
member who
was on parole and violated his parole
should have been in prison with their
two backed up recall that piece of [ __ ]
recalled that so
so because he was he went to jail they
slap on the wrist for beating his wife
with a gun
he pulls a knife on the on his wife his
wife goes this isn't safe i'm gonna go
to hotel he later that night falls to
the hotel she calls the cops goes my uh
my husband's here and with a knife he's
trying to kill me we need to do
something two cops show up he ambushes
him kills both of them and then he
doesn't shoot out the cops dies
but prior to that
violated pearl oh yeah multiple-time
criminal yeah and garcon slap on the
wrist
talk to a cop about this right now you
will [ __ ] be ready to run through a
[ __ ] brick i lose my mind over it
about garcon
it was predictable that's what la and
the people that vote him in are people a
lot of times the people that support
someone like gaston are people that live
in gated communities or have their own
private security talk about it talk to
cops about the the garshan right now
talk to him but also but with garcon
remember garcon was the day in san
francisco it's a [ __ ] show up there to
me that'd be like i got all that that
boy that'd be that'd be like a
quarterback throwing 40 interceptions
yeah and the broncos be like you know
what i like what he did
yeah we'll take 100 and then he throws
50 or 70 like what the [ __ ] how could we
know
a lot of cat news today one more to go
oh yeah hey there we go this wasn't that
graphic
i think they ended it but it's another
cat
and this is all
all just randomly showed up i didn't
type in dangerous cats no this is dirt
well this guy just loves it right like i
would never like
you just
it's feeding
so it is a pretty graphic beat because
this right and then it cuts to that yeah
yeah yeah well he got his hand you know
what's horrific this video
he's
also the guy recording could you jump in
and help the guy yeah he's like holy
[ __ ] world star
was a girl i think it was a girl filming
also you probably have better luck if
there's not a fence there because you're
pulling away and a cat's not going to
let go of something pulling you could
almost like go in like you can play with
a cat and go into it i didn't know he
died yeah jesus was rushed to the
hospital where he refused to allow
doctors to amputate his badly mangled
hand by the tiger before dying of a
heart attack he's only 23 years old so
that was terrible for him he went
through such shock and he's like no just
leave my hand like
why what hand that is
that's that's george's people that
happens i didn't know he died of grief
people will die of grief oh that that's
good that that school shooter that shot
his wife who's a teacher the next day he
died of heart
stress broken heart yeah yeah stress
that's right horrible yeah but mark the
point of all these things
yeah he brought these yeah
cats aren't a reason to stick anywhere
yeah
you're gonna have to that's why i'm
doing this
that's why i'm doing all this you're
gonna have to put those cats down man no
no just leave them just leave them
my point
is cats yeah
carry on chin we might have to edit that
so mark doesn't get in trouble why why
not nothing
it's a deep cut
uh i think that's pretty much it yeah
unless you guys want to hear about the
eagle eradication oh yeah somebody the
eagle what the eagle eradication
alliance which somebody posted on the
last clip that we posted because we're
talking about eagles
and uh this is a joke page where it's
like we need to get rid of all you guys
it's like turn around he's flying past i
do love this kind of stuff like birds
aren't real because people are taking it
super seriously pigeons are spies yeah
yeah
i believe in that what i love most is
like eagle eradication american
relationships like aoc and tech crews to
come together
marmot mice and bulls who are great
patriots like aoc and ted cruz aoc is
out of her mind this is not at this
point aoc is just doing stuff for
clickbait
she's she's no different than the
youtuber yeah like some of the [ __ ] she
says like why is that true yeah yeah
yeah she's going somewhere evie's dude
what would you say i said she's got the
heavies that what's that oh titties yeah
she's like she's
she's attractive i've only seen those
like deep fakes where it's like her face
on like a porn star or something like
and i thought it was real i said it to a
friend because that's not right it's a
bummer she's so attractive it'd be way
better if she was like a warlock
she's out of her mind i read a weird
thing there that she is hot she's so hot
go to the news though chin she's hot
right then read this
yeah what is it what is it
if you go to the news or spark this uh
yeah but she thinks we should all die
because we're white guys
this one
you know i kind of agree with her though
she calls me an oppressor and i don't
support a lot of white guilt i'm not a
colonizer or an oppressor no you're not
no she's didn't do anything no no sorry
my denial right kids
it's your fault
she's just attractive
then she went to the met gala and wore
that like
five thousand dollar dress that was
talking about who she married the rich
yeah
that's her smart being a wealthy i've
never heard that before do you imagine
being her husband like would you just
shut up for two seconds that guy
oh redhead don't trust him that guy a
giant redhead dude that guy's such a
[ __ ] imagine being married like you're
just
like she's married to a white guy
with a red beard correct the redhead
she's full of [ __ ] i don't think she
believes any of the stuff she's saying
she is gorgeous she can't believe all
the stuff she's saying if that's her
husband
dude i bet she comes in she's like
where's dinner [ __ ]
hey fire
hey fire crotch where the [ __ ] my
mirror exactly and he's uh i'm so sorry
hey cuck boy where's my toast he looks
like a giant though he looks like a
giant man oh wow he went and some of
them he looks strong and then some of me
looks weak yeah
jesus chris who is that i know what is
going on that's right the thing cnn says
tax the rich although it's it costs 150
000 to eat a meal at that oh they're not
married
oh they're engaged boyfriend yeah
interesting right yeah
a single vice president has that ever
happened oh sh oh she's not gonna vote
not chance not a chance no no we learned
our lesson with kamala harris yeah
who's also back in the day very
attractive yep that's crazy but her
you're not messing she has some
political sweater hitters i am such an
idiot she has some
liberal hitters dude i thought that was
the vice president oh no
i can i get how you can see that no you
don't follow politics no he's like i
don't follow you you know no she's not
going to get in i was like
i don't follow nba he's always come over
here
well there we have it well it's a good
thing brendan doesn't know what the vice
president is jeff die is not political
ladies and gentlemen yeah he knows his
sports no yeah
you now you're with me at the shop and
friends on wednesday yes sir me adam
carla trevor wallace it's gonna be good
uh craig we have a very special guest
coming yes he's gonna be beast and then
where are you at and then not this
weekend but next weekend i'm at uh cb
live in phoenix arizona i love that room
i love those shows please come and then
mike drop comedy club in san diego it's
a new club it's a great club on their
july 22nd 23rd and then tampa florida in
august it'll be fun two nights i'm gonna
try and throw out a first place for the
raise while i'm out there
good team yeah and uh my least favorite
team so those are those are the dates
come come check them out they're gonna
be fun and then like i said i'm sorry
like i said uh jeff and i will be at the
improv wednesday night with trevor
wallace adam carolla craig and then a
very special guest at shobhan friends
one show only at eight p.m in hollywood
california hollywood improv and then the
trash panda summer tour continues in
fort wayne indiana july 14th through the
16th san diego california's july 21st to
23rd at the laugh factor in the heart of
san diego baltimore is august 4th
through the 6th and then just add is
appleton wisconsin september 8th through
the 10th houston's on there boston's on
there get your tickets at f a t k z.com
or thinkboy.com also thinkboy.com i
didn't know they were doing this big of
a discount uh it's 50 off the entire
goddamn website 50 off just for father's
day that ends i think sunday night go to
thinkboy.com right now for the father's
day sale this is for all the dads out
there you get 50 off you're welcome nice
uh brookfield wisconsin milwaukee improv
july 21 22-23 get yourself some austin
texas cap city july 28th to the 30th
nashville tennessee zany's august 25th
four great clubs there big great clubs
and then uh my my episode best of um
doing well on youtube and we got another
one right now yep another one dropping
on monday every monday we're going to be
dropping the best of every monday yes
sir is this going up today sir
no no no no no no
oh yeah so
today monday or wednesday yeah so this
this uh brian as you guys are listening
brian's in greece i'm in grace brian's a
and i've i've i have my skeptical hip
lies about this uh you know private jet
grease yeah you're a toilet girl you
know what i'm talking about you think so
you're going to be doing something for
that private jet you think so man yeah i
will do so you're going to take out
those invisaligns daddy's going to work
right yeah i got to take the lines out
do you want me to lose these you don't
get to go to greece for free right
you're i'm gonna be paying i will say
nobody on the boat speaks english so i
don't know what that means but
i know i'm wearing something
they have they have an outfit you wear
some in america we're in the american
flag yeah so that's it so i apologize
it's gonna be [ __ ] sick it's gonna be
hot all right kids we love you jeff dye
you're the best thanks for having me
finally
in the last bro we're out